around the country
and around the world a death gun salute
for the life lost
41 rounds fired over 41 minutes
at edinburgh castle so too
at cardiff castle
[Music]
at hillsborough castle in northern
ireland
and at the tower of london
this is um probably the most significant
occasion
um in in our lifetime and for the
regiment it's really important
for us to be able to be a part of it
today at woolwich barracks
the salute by the king's troop royal
horse artillery
involved the 13-pounder field guns fired
for prince phillips wedding to the queen
in 1947
[Music]
and at the coronation six years later
and every november thereafter
for their wedding anniversary
royal navy guns were fired at portsmouth
and on the warships hms diamond and hms
montrose
rounds were fired at sea for a
distinguished ex-serviceman
this was the scene in london's
piccadilly circus
there was a visual tribute too on bt
tower
in all corners of the country it was a
day for remembrance and respect
prince philip was a great man
we all grew up knowing him
and it's a great loss and i think the
queen is going to be um
lost without him well i come from the
cybers
and so when somebody dies
would you like to go and shop for
respect i've
just come to leia road on behalf of my
grandparents obviously because the
pandemic and
their asian stuff they're stuck indoors
and i know they're real royalists and
would appreciate
the gesture it wasn't just the uk that
gave us ceremonial salute
guns were fired in the australian
capital canberra
so too in gibraltar
the guns fired a minute apart for the
duke of edinburgh
represent the echo of a tolling bell for
the most senior military officers
it is a distinction rarely afforded
enacted this weekend for a rare
contribution in life
and legacy james matthews sky news
edinburgh